okay after uh making some plots there
are a few other topics um in the lab
that we're we're going to not go through
in the interest of time um and you can
see if you ever want to know the subp
parts of the lab you can use this sort
of table of contents tab here so um we
have some examples about how to access
data in arrays and how to use slices in
general for sequences in Python um that
is important but I think more important
we're going to is to talk about data
frame so we're going to jump here to
this loading data um part of the lab
Okay so we've talked now about nump
arrays um which are representations of
numbers in the
computer there are lots of you know lots
of ways to represent data in a computer
not all data is numeric um and so we
need there's an object that's some
something like an array or a matrix but
it's called a data frame that is sort of
uh familiar in many many languages that
for data analysis so the library that
implements data frames in Python is uh
the pandas library or that's the the
default Library so if you have a a data
file um here this is a so-called CSV
file we can read it in using pandas and
if you want we can take a quick look at
the data file so here's the uh the auto
data file and I'm going to open it up so
we can see what it looks like and it's
in a file uh the first row is the the
column name and then the data is
separated by columns I see so there's
there's numbers as well as um
categorical um yeah these these names
here this is the name of the this is a
file about uh different models of cars I
think it's from the late 70s or 80s uh
and has some measurements on each model
of car so you can see that you need
something in the computer to represent
the model of car it's different than a
than MPG an MPG is a decimal number
right but um some columns will be
numbers and some will be um character
vectors yes that's the the the the big
distinction between a data data frame
and an array is an array all the entries
kind of have to be the same type a data
frame they can be different types
um okay so these files here I've copied
them from uh from the data directory if
you go back this is the directory on the
desktop in the data directory there the
auto files I've just copied them back
into this uh
into this Jupiter notebook file so that
the computer knows where to find
them um
okay let's go back
to where we were and let's get rid of
the
sidebar
okay okay so we're going to read in the
file and let's take a look at a data
frame um well we see it has these
columns that those are the that's the
first row of the data file we saw and we
see these uh it has recognize that the
name column were strings and some
columns were floats here it has a
decimal for the acceleration so it
recognize that should be treated as a
float and that should be treated as a I
think this example also shows Jonathan
that um a CSV file is a good format for
inputting data because it's got the
column names and and and you just had to
read it and everything was preserved
yeah uh yes yes CSV is a very very
common format for um for d for tabular
data that can that we can think of as
having you know the where the rows are
each corresponding a different car here
or a different person and the columns
are different measurements on each of
the row variables yeah that makes it
nice and easy
yeah okay um there's another version of
the file let's let's move on from that
so we can access columns by using the
same sort of square bracket notation we
saw for arrays but here we can give a
column name so Auto horsepower is going
to be um those numbers we saw in the
horsepower column above there's a
comment in the lab here that says this
should be an object data type that's
because I skipped a line and let's just
do
that just to be honest the reason this
is called the this is not recognized as
float and that's because there are some
uh missing values represented by
question mark so I've looked at the
unique values in a in the array and I've
see there are some it's everything is
treated here as a string you can see
that by the quotes and there was a
question mark So when pandas tried to
read it in it didn't recognize them all
as floats we have to tell it something
is a is a represents of missing values
oh cursed missing values yes it's the
curse of data analysis yes and here we
only have a few but of course most data
has you know a lot of missing values
um so that's not a problem if we know
what the how missing values are
represented we can give it
uh a
uh a a set of possible missing value
strings um and now we see it actually is
a uh represented as a float because when
I compute it sum it gives me a number
whereas earlier if they were all strings
the sum would be a string of course so
when you when you do the sum it skips
over the missing values uh well actually
know this one I've reread it in with the
missing values I see and if we look at
horsepower this will now be a float
instead of an object oh I see so it it
uh removed the rows um where there was a
oh so it removed the rows where they
were missing but uh well it notes the
rows I should say I see yes and when it
did the sum it does skip over them okay
yes so to actually get rid of all the
the entries with missing values we can
use this drop na method and we see that
instead of having 397 we get 392 entries
so that means there were five rows that
had a question mark and so in this case
it was reasonable just to drop the rows
with missing Val yes only five were
effective okay so a few things we'll
want to do is often we'll want to select
Columns of a data frame and rows of a
data frame so we can find the columns by
looking at the columns
method and uh well there are several
ways to index data in a data frame if we
only want the first three this is an
example of using a the slice notation R
colon 3 gives us the first three entries
the first three rows of the data frame
and um these are
them you can also if you have like a
test if you want to find all you know
cars that were created after 1980 you
can make this Boolean vector
and uh selecting with a Boolean Vector
will give you all the cars that were
created after
1980 um okay now rows and columns are
also you know we'll sometimes want to do
select both and let me just get rid of
this this is annoyingly big um okay for
several columns if we give a list of
columns this will give us a new data
frame with only those two columns um and
there are actually quite a few examples
here of inding that I it's important I
think you go through uh many of them but
I but I we won't go through all of them
I want to wrap up this topic on data
frames by talking about um uh plotting
from a data frame so when we have
variables in a data
frame I'm just going to move on to the
plotting
part and uh as you see there is a lot of
content in the labs that we won't be
able to get through in these videos and
it's important that that you uh you
follow through the when doing the
homeworks
okay so for this this first lab is also
intended for for people who don't know
Python and so they'll be learning python
for the first time and so is it
necessary it's necessary for them to go
through a lot of yes this is this is a a
longer lab than than several the other
ones and that's because this is the
first lab
um okay so suppose we want to um uh
plot uh so a I just this last little
example here shows how um data frames
are sort of aware of um self-aware in
terms of plots so that is a data frame
has a plotting method so first
um well we we might want to there are
columns called horsepower and MPG in in
the auto and we might think we could
just plot them by using the plot method
of course there's nothing called
horsepower so the computer's going to
complain and there's nothing called
miles per gallon it will say we'll get
an error this is a an example of what
python shows you when you run code that
is gives an invalid output it's called
an exception and it rightly says there's
no variable called horsepower there is a
column called horsepower in Auto and so
we can if we do the following this will
give us the horsepower values that will
be easy to find and the mpg values and
we can make a scatter plot
okay but data frame uh data frames as I
said actually um know something about
how to make a plot so instead of
directly plotting with to the axis you
can call the plot method of a data frame
and so here we can make that same
scatter plot using the plot. scatter
method and let's just run
this and what ax has returned is an axis
like the axe we saw when we made the
plots above so we can set the title of
the axis we could set the xlabel we
could do all the other things we do to a
regular AIS but for plotting certain
things um from a data frame uh the data
frame can often help us
out